[Musique]
ski de ville du côlon
Et plus que ton laissez-passer pour me faire un rabais quoi
le football
et cd
nous sommes le bus
ils sont déjà un nom
Oh
plein
sinus fini
et
vous avez besoin de réducteurs mondiaux si vous y allez
avec votre salle à manger actuelle est moins formel
le rapport qui est venu
d'abord mais après la musique
je vais comme le métal
dans mon esprit confirmé si votre attitude
nouvelles de newkirk qu'est-ce qu'il a accompli
où ils nous veulent et je me montre
J'ai aussi commandé plus de denim sur le web
c'est toujours que je suis tu sais
être excité
aussi des médicaments cotillo
au-delà
était sec a été interrogé pour le module qui
elle allait signer avec son mec
tutu l 22 amour
et la prochaine tu prends que tu le
bronze
ou demandé d'avoir été coupé
le bouquetin et ils ont dit
[Musique]
je n'ai pas mangé
premier
de citi cannes à brasilia
[Musique]
je
Aux débuts
et là elle n'est pas sortie
la fente du portier de scène
ré
[des rires]
et sentir le travail
Hé bien oui
et si tu
[Musique]